quindi una sera la mia presentazione
naturalmente non potrà essere molto
allegra perché trattiamo di un argomento
che fra i più seri perché i drammatici
al mondo
io ho iniziato a occuparmi di trimani
molti molti anni fa ero uno studente e
alla prima iniziativa che feci un
signore di un'agenzia internazionale che
si occupava di rifugiati mi disse stai
attento tu con questa voglia che ha di
occuparti i diritti umani i rischi di
occupartene tutta la vita aveva ragione
parliamo di quello che è successo negli
anni in cui mi sono occupato di diritti
umani per arrivare a questa ultima sfida
che una delle cose più importanti che mi
abbiano chiamato a fare intanto una cosa
che io ritengo molto importante cambiare
è possibile
noi affrontiamo tragedie normalmente
tutta la questione della pena di morte
né versione molto drammatica ma in
generale il mondo è pieno liberazione
dei diritti umani quella che vedete
l'assemblea generale delle nazioni unite
con tutto il suo carico di problemi di
incongruenze di difficoltà ma a volte è
possibile nelle istituzioni
internazionali grazie al movimento
internazionale alle società civile
giungere a qualche cambiamento positivo
e poi questa serie di incontri e
intitolata biondo storia di chi non si è
fermato di chi è andato oltre le
frontiere qualche anno fa ebbe l'idea di
fare una rivista che si chiamava proprio
la nuova frontiera international human
rights and security review la copertina
che vedete è su un caso di una persona
condannata a morte allora in nigeria con
esso tocchi caino facemmo una missione e
poi si riuscì a salvare quella donna
dall'esecuzione ma dicevo il mondo il
mondo cambia cambiano le frontiere
quella è una foto che fece quando c'era
ancora
il muro di berlino e molti pensavano che
sarebbe rimasto per sempre per fortuna
così non è stato quelli che pensavano
che sarebbe rimasto per sempre la
chiamavano real politik la politica
della realtà invece era molto più reale
immaginare un futuro diverso lì in mezzo
ci sono io con altre due persone portati
via da 18 agente della polizia della
germania est
dopo una manifestazione al muro il muro
crollò pochi mesi dopo
non dico a casa nostra però insomma
qualche spintarella e la demo e pochi
mesi dopo l'altra babele nell'allora
cecoslovacchia che entrava e usciva dal
carcere fu portato a furor di popolo
diremmo al castello cioè la presidenza
della repubblica scoppiarono le guerre
nell'ex jugoslavia eccole le frontiere
che cambiano che cambiano
drammaticamente ho fatto alcune attività
da reporter freelance e questa è la
prima guerra di cecenia nel 95 ma nello
stesso tempo si cominciava a parlare
della possibilità proprio di abolire la
pena di morte in stati che l'hanno avuta
fino a non molti anni fa e questa è una
conferenza che riuscimmo organizzare a
mosca 20 anni fa quasi nel novembre del
96 verso il terzo millennio senza la
pena di morte nei paesi della comunita
di stati indipendenti
certo non non basta fare le conferenze i
processi ed il cambiamento sono
estremamente complessi contraddittori
tant'è che e vediamo se parte l'altra ed
è positiva tant'è che sappiamo che
esistono delle crisi molto importanti
tuttora con dei conflitti anche armati
nella stessa europa questa
un'immagine della quale ringrazio in
particolare e vasileva che con noi del
di una manifestazione a maidan nella
piazza più importante di kiev e dove ho
trovato molto simbolico questo avere
insieme alla bandiera khrin a una
bandiera europea è questa questa l'unica
credo immagine che vedrete senza nessuna
scritta questa e parigi a ottobre del
2015 io ero di base a parigi da da poche
settimane e dopo avere visto in molti
paesi del mondo guerre rivoluzioni colpi
di stato
eventi tragici potevo non aspettarmi di
vederlo anche a parigi dove lavoravo
dove lavoro tuttora ancora per qualche
mese
e invece pochi giorni dopo avvenne come
sappiamo la tragedia del 13 novembre con
oltre 100 130 morti dopo quello qualcuno
disse che occorreva addirittura
reintrodurre la pena di morte in francia
e in altri paesi europei
la cosa più paradossale qualcuno disse
ci vorrebbe la pena di morte per i
kamikaze che è una delle cose più
assurde perché esattamente quello che
cercano vendetta o giustizia questa è
un'alternativa importante
ne parlammo già in in kazakistan in
kazakistan sono vissuto per quasi tre
anni dirigendo progetto per i diritti
umani è una delle cose che riuscimmo a
fare con varie organizzazioni fu
promuovere il superamento anche dai
codici non soltanto di fatto della pena
di morte in quel paese qui c'è qualche
riassunto della situazione della pena di
morte rispetto al diritto internazionale
non troverete nel diritto internazionale
una norma che la vieta espressamente per
tutti gli stati ovunque ma c'è una
tendenza
a limitarla il più possibile ea vietarla
soltanto perché abbia firmato un patto a
questo specificamente relativo la pena
capitale è soggetta a limitazioni
secondo il patto internazionale sui
diritti civili e politici del 1966 e
serve un processo equo con determinate
garanzie ammissibile soltanto per i
crimini più gravi non è applicabile
retroattivamente cioè non si può essere
condannati a morte per un reato che non
era passibile di pena di morte prima che
venisse commesso deve essere garantito
sempre il diritto al condannato a
chiedere la grazia alla commutazione
della pena e non possono essere
condannati a morte persone che avevano
meno di 18 anni al momento del reato né
può essere eseguita la sentenza per
donne incinta la situazione nel mondo
ora questa mappa mostra i paesi che sono
abolizionisti per tutti i tipi di
crimini
secondo questo calcolo di ensemble e
contro la pena di morte che
l'organizzazione per la quale ho pero
attualmente a parigi sono 98 i calcoli
sono leggermente diversi per altre
organizzazioni come vedremo ci sono
sette paesi abolizionisti solo per
crimini comuni non per esempio per
crimini di guerra 35 sono abolizionisti
di fatto ci sono paesi dove esiste la
pena di morte ma non viene eseguita da
almeno dieci anni
e poi ci sono i paesi detenzioni sti che
sono circa 60 secondo nessuno tocchi
caino sono 103 gli stati completamente
abolizionisti se lo sono per crimini
ordinari sei hanno una moratoria è
ufficiale e 40 se li possiamo
considerare abolizionisti di fatto
quelli che sono effettivamente
mantenitori sotto tutti i punti di vista
cioè de iure ed è fatto sono attualmente
36 qui ne vedete l'elenco sono quasi
tutti stati al regime autoritario
alcuni sono degli stati democratici in
particolare come ben sappiamo gli stati
uniti ma anche il giappone per esempio
ci sono degli argomenti piuttosto tipici
di coloro che ancora sostengono la pena
di morte un fine retributivo cioè
l'equivalenza con il danno causato alle
vittime il ristabilimento di un ordine
morale generale in particolare per
genocidio o per crimini contro l'umanità
la prevenzione perché si sostiene che la
pena di morte avrebbe un effetto
deterrente e una certa compensazione
psicologica per i familiari delle
vittime
naturalmente rispetto a tutti questi
argomenti a favore ce ne sono
altrettanti contrari il più importante
credo sia proprio quello che c'è
differenza fra vendetta e giustizia
ristabilimento di un ordine morale
generale è difficile sostenere che sia
morale quando il potere pubblico uccide
l'effetto deterrente non è provato e
anzi tutte le statistiche mostrano che
quando uno stato buonissimo pena di
morte non aumenta il livello di
criminalità la compensazione psicologica
per i familiari delle vittime in realtà
non è richiesta è sempre meno e
richiesta dai familiari delle vittime
sono in contatto ormai con molti di loro
e il trauma senz'altro può essere meglio
superato con dei programmi di
riabilitazione psicologica e con un
riconoscimento sociale diffuso l'italia
un ruolo storico in questo c'era almeno
dall epoca di cesare beccaria quindi
parliamo di 262 anni fa e poi in
particolare in toscana leopoldo ii
granduca leopoldo di toscana il 30
novembre 1786 pubblicava alla legge che
aboliva la
pena di morte nel granducato poi
parzialmente introdotta per alcuni casi
nuovamente abolita
l'italia la bohli col codice zanardelli
il regno d'italia a fine ottocento fu
reintrodotta sotto il fascismo e
finalmente abolita nella nostra
costituzione
c'è una campagna per la moratoria
universale in corso penso che lo
sappiate la diapositiva riassume alcuni
elementi iniziamo dal 94 ad occuparsene
con nessuno tocchi caino
si arriva infine dopo diversi tentativi
nel 2007 alla prima produzione da parte
dell'assemblea generale dell'onu che
avevo citato all'inizio con 104 voti a
favore 54 contrari 29 astensioni
si è poi votata altre moto ormai la
rivoluzione di biennale si voterà ancora
alla prossima sessione assemblea
generale quest'anno l'ultima volta il
2014 i voti a favore sono salite a 117 e
38 sono stati i contrari 34 le sessioni
per cui c'è un trend è positivo da
questo punto di vista noi conosciamo
molto lobbying con governi con
parlamenti e presso l'opinione pubblica
naturalmente e quindi siamo abbastanza
convinti che i progressi possono essere
sensibili da questo punto di vista c'è
certamente il caso degli stati uniti
quello degli stati uniti è il caso più
famoso ma questo non vuol dire che gli
stati uniti siano lo stato che esegue
più sentenze di morte
tant'è che dall inizio 2015 ad oggi sono
avvenute secondo soltanto 35 esecuzioni
in particolare sono avvenute soltanto in
pochi stati il texas soprattutto e pochi
altri
l'opinione pubblica internazionale e
colpita dal fatto che che se ne parla e
perché su questo sono stati realizzati
film documentari
ne parlano i media molto importante ci
aiuta nella campagna internazionale per
l'abolizione e aiuta anche l'opinione
pubblica a fare pressione in alcuni
stati purtroppo ancora in texas
perché la pena di morte venga
abolita o sensibilmente ridotta quello
che ti accennavo c'è l'abolizione degli
usa in alcuni stati sempre di più si va
verso un'abolizione de facto ma ci sono
dei casi particolarmente gravi che
colpiscono molto io ho qualche settimana
fa ho presentato un film nell'ambito di
un festival documenta rischio che ho
sentito la human rights human rome's e
sulla storia vera di niki haris c'è
questo film che consiste essenzialmente
in una lunga intervista con mi chiarisca
è stato oltre 21 anni nel braccio della
morte in pennsylvania per un'accusa di
un omicidio che non aveva commesso ormai
stava impazzendo ora
arrivato a desiderare soltanto i suicidi
finalmente dopo anni in cui chiedeva che
venisse fatto è stato scagionato grazie
al test del dna che vive attualmente in
gran bretagna spero di averlo con noi
congresso di osso di cui parlerò fra
qualche istante il titolo del film sulla
sua vita ed è fiero of certain la paura
del del 13 del numero 13 si chiama così
perché lui fu salvato oltre che dal dna
fu salvato psicologicamente da una cosa
dai libri a un certo punto in questi
molti anni di isolamento in braccio
della morte
inizio a procurarsi libri a leggerli a
leggere cose che non aveva neanche mai
pensato che potessero esistere come la
parola di origine greca frisca ide caffo
be a tree schede kb e rimase molto
impresso che cosa vuol dire vuol dire
paura del numero 13
e questo segna la sua ristrutturazione
mentale il suo desiderio di continuare a
vivere di farcela ce la sta facendo
sono altri argomenti contrari uno dei
più importanti naturalmente il fatto che
l'esecuzione è qualcosa di irreversibile
in caso di errore giudiziario non si può
tornare indietro ma il primo esecutore
al mondo in rapporto alla popolazione è
il regime iraniano il primo in valori
assoluti e la cina che però ha un trend
fortunatamente in discesa
sono passati in pochi anni da circa
6.000 esecuzioni all'anno a circa 2.500
in cina l'iran
purtroppo sta incrementando il numero di
pena di morte di e di esecuzioni ogni
anno sono state circa 1.000 nel solo
2015 una delle cose che sostengo di cui
mi occupo molto è il relativismo
culturale io credo che sia il momento di
superare l'idea di un relativismo
culturale cioè il pensare che ci siano
stati come alcuni dei nostri dove i
diritti umani possono essere rispettati
e altri dove non debbano esserlo perché
perché fanno parte del sud perché ci
sono altre e tradizioni io credo che ci
sia uno come ci sono i diritti umani
universali e anche quello alla giustizia
e non alla vendetta penso che sia
importante ovunque
tant'è che ci sono movimenti
abolizionisti anche in paesi arabi
questi sono organizzazioni con cui ansap
contro la prende morte e partner
rispettivamente in marocco e in tunisia
e in tunisia avevano questo slogan la
pena di morte e nuoce gravemente
all'umanità
ecco ensemble contro la pende morte
insieme contro la pena di morte e
l'organizzazione con la quale ho pero
attualmente acting for abolition quindi
unire gli abolizionisti in tutto il
mondo lavorare con partner locali e
sollevare la consapevolezza pubblica e
lavorare anche
per coloro che sono stati condannati a
morte e il sesto congresso come è stato
ricordato farà del 21 a 23 giugno ad
oslo
cercheremo di lavorare insieme con
centinaia e centinaia di attivisti ma
anche con governi con personalità
internazionali per questo abbiamo la
sponsorship di alcuni governi in
particolare quello norvegese quello
italiano anche contribuisce al successo
del congresso e avremo l'alto
commissario proietti mai delle nazioni
unite il quartetto nazionale tunisino
che l'ultimo premio nobel per la pace e
dico vediamoci addosso lo io spero che
alcuni di voi che siete in sala possono
essere presenti fra le circa 1.500
persone che noi attendiamo per fare
networking per lavorare insieme su
questo avremo anche le testimonianze di
alcuni ex condannati a morte
riconosciuti innocenti spero che sia con
noi anche nicolis e infine voi sappiate
che potete trovarmi potete scrivermi
possiamo cercare di capire cosa fare
insieme contro la pena di morte per i
diritti in maniera il mondo
vi ringrazio